اندلعت اشتباكات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومتظاهرين رافضين لقانون تمديد سن التقاعد
في عدد من المدن الفرنسيه وفي باريس عطل
المتظاهرون حركه الطريق واشعلوا النيران
في الشوارع فيما اطلقت الشرطه الغاز
المسيل للدموع لتفريقهم تاتي الاحتجاجات
بعد يوم من فشل اجتماعي رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث مع قاده النقابات وهذه الصور هي
من باريس حيث هذه الاحتجاجات ما زالت
مستمره وهناك بعض المواجهات بين الشرطه
والمحتاجين طبعا هذه الاحتجاجات خرجت منذ
اسابيع ردا على سن التقاعد او رفضا ايضا
على موضوع رفع سن التقاعد في فرنسا
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
للشرطه الفرنسيه التي
تحاول ان تفرق المتظاهرين في باريس هذه
الاحتياجات ما زالت مستمره طيله هذا اليوم
في باريس وعدد من المدن الفرنسيه
وايضا هناك هذه المظاهرات ما زالت مستمره
منذ اسابيع حيث ان المتظاهرين مازالوا
متمسكين بمطلبهم تجاه موضوع سن التقاعد
بينما الحكومه والرئيس الفرنسي ايضا ما
زالوا مصرين على قرارهم حتى ان الرئيس
الفرنسي كان ذكر بان هذا القرار لن يعود
عنه حتى ولو افقده الكثير من شعبيته ما
زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من باريس
للمتظاهرين الذين ما يزال هنا متواجدين
الاعداد هي بالعشرات كما نتابع ومنذ قليل
ايضا في هذه الصوره كنا تابعنا تواجد كثيف
للشرطه الفرنسيه
المتواجده في الشوارع في باريس
لمواجهه هذه التظاهرات
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
وطبعا بعد قليل سيكون معنا زميلنا حسين
قنيبر ليطلعنا ايضا على هذا النهار الطويل
كيف كانت مجرياته واين تركزت هذه
المظاهرات وما هي الجهود التي تبذل لحل
هذه الازمه التي ما زالت مستمره منذ
اسابيع اذا زميلنا حسين قنيبر اصبح جاهزا
معنا حسين هل يمكن ان توجز لنا هذا النهار
طويل من الاحتياجات في باريس ومختلف المدن
الفرنسيه
مساء الخير ميسون وانا اجيبك على سؤالك
نترك الكاميرا تتحرك لتنقل المشهد هنا في
بلاستيتالي لبلاس ديتالي ساحه ايطاليا
المشهد يبدو على شكل التالي مجموعات من
المتظاهرين لم تتفرق بعد هذا ما بقي منهم
الشرطه ستعمد لاحقا الى تفريقهم او تفريق
من بقي منهم على مستوى فرنسا تظاهر اليوم
حوالى مليونير شخص في كل فرنسا كما تقول
النقابات فيما تتحدث وزاره الداخليه عن
570 الف متظاهر فقط عبر فرنسا بكاملها من
بينهم 57 في باريس وحدها بحسب ارقام وزاره
الداخليه طبعا النقابات تتحدث دائما عن
بغداد اكبر من اعداد وزاره الداخليه خلال
المواجهات التي جرت هنا وفي مواقع اخرى من
العاصمه الفرنسيه جرح
154 شخصا
واوقفت الشرطه مئه واحد عشر شخصا عفوا
الجرحى من بين عناصر الشرطه هم 154
عنصرا
والموقفون من بين المتظاهرين هو عددهم
احد عشر
وطبعا
النقبات اعلنت كعادتها عند نهايه كل
تظاهرات تعلن عن موعد التحرك المقبل هي
اعلنت عن موعد التحرك المقبل الخميس في
الثالث عشر من هذا الشهر اي بعد اسبوع
وهذا التوقيت له دلالاته لانه ياتي قبل
يوم واحد على موعد الاصدار المجلس
الدستوري قراره بشان قانون رفع سن التقاعد
سيحدد المجلس الدستوري في الرابع عشر من
هذا الشهر فاذا كان رفع سن التقاعد مخالفا
ام موافقا للدستور هذا بعض من المشهد هنا
بالنسبه للمخارج بالنسبه للحلول المطروحه
المقبوله اقله من المتظاهرين ومن الحكومه
والرئيس الفرنسي هل يمكن ان تطلعنا عليها
هل هناك من حلول مطروحه الان
في الواقع حلول مختلفه باختلاف الفريق
الذي يرى كيف يمكن ان تكون النقابات لدى
لقاء ممثليها يوم امس برئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث بورن طالبت باعتماد حل وحيد لا
يوجد غيره كما تقول النقبات وهو سحب قانون
رفع سن التقاعد فورا الحكومه تقول ان هذا
لا يمكن ان يكون حلا لان نظام التقاعد
يعاني من
عجز في ميزانيته سيبلغ هذا العجز 20
مليارا عام 2030 وبالتالي
للحفاظ على نظام التقاعد لجميع الفرنسيين
لابد من ان يعمل الفرنسيون عامين اضافيين
تجنبا الانهيار نظام التقاعد ماليا تقول
الحكومه في كل الاحوال المخارج لا تبدو
متاحه المجلس الدستوري اما ان يقبل قانون
رفع سن التقاعد كل بدوده يعتبره دستوريا
او انه يعتبر بعض بنوده دستوري والبعض
الاخر غير دستوري او ان يقبل بكل البنود
يعتبرها موافقه لبنود الدستور او يرفضه
بكامله هذه فرضيات كثيره لننتظر الى
الرابع عشر من هذا الشهر لنعرف كيف سيكون
قرار المجلس الدستوري سيسبق قراره تحرك
جديد كما ذكرت الخميس المقبل في الثالث
عشر من هذا شهر تشاهدين ما يجري خلفي
عناصر الشرطه
يحاصرون اعدادا من الشبان والشباب الذين
ما زالوا يتظاهرون هنا في ساحه كلاس
ديتالي
شكرا لك يا حسين مدير مكتب العربيه حسين
قنيبر كنت معي من باريس حيث اطلعتنا على
الصوره بشكل واضح على ما يجري الان في
شوارع باريس